A legendary warrior-queen, 10,000
ships, and one heck of a shattered
glass ceiling — but what does any of
this have to do with House of the Dragon?
In "The Black Queen," the first season
finale of HBO's massively successful
Game of Thrones prequel House of the Dragon,
the Targaryen civil war known as the Dance
of the Dragons begins in earnest. In the
Green corner, you've got Alicent Hightower,
the widow of King Viserys Targaryen and
mother to Aegon Targaryen, the young king
she just installed on the Iron Throne. As
for the Blacks, there's Rhaenyra Targaryen,
daughter to Viserys and his intended heir,
who has spent her whole life preparing to
sit on the throne. Once childhood friends and
confidantes, these two women have spent their
adult years completely at odds, especially as
their children have fought amongst each other.
During the events of "The Black Queen,"
Alicent's father and Hand of the King
Otto Hightower tries to bargain with
Rhaenyra on his daughter's behalf,
and in doing so, he brings her a small token
of the former friendship between the two women.
When Otto approaches Rhaenyra and
her formidable husband Daemon on
the bridge that leads to Dragonstone,
he tries to make a bargain with them:
if they bend the knee to Aegon and accept him
as their king, he'll let Rhaenyra and her sons
keep Dragonstone. He also suggests that her
sons will serve as squires and cupbearers to
Alicent's children. Daemon definitely doesn't
mince words about his feelings on the matter.
Understandably, Rhaenyra feels the
same way, going so far as to throw
Otto's pin, signifying his status as Hand,
into the sea. This betrayal of Rhaenyra's
father's wishes clearly infuriates both
her and Daemon, but at the last minute,
Otto produces a gift from Alicent meant for
Rhaenyra that seems to soften her just a little.
Otto gives Rhaenyra an envelope containing
a torn page from a book that she and
Alicent read together when they were
young. That page focuses on Nymeria,
a fierce warrior who brought a fleet of
10,000 ships across the Narrow Sea when she
faced attacks from enemies in Valyria. When the
two girls read it in the show's first episode,
they're still close friends, and clearly the
page brings back some memories for Rhaenyra.
"What are you doing?"
"So you remember."
Alicent seems to be missing a huge part of the
story, however, in that Nymeria ended up taking
over the region of Dorne and ruling as queen.
After her husband Mors Martell died in battle,
Nymeria became a warrior in her own
right, and vanquished enough of her
opponents to fully rule Dorne and end
the tradition of male primogeniture.
As both Rhaenys and Rhaenyra have directly
told Alicent during House of the Dragon,
the widowed queen has proven herself to be
perfectly happy to follow the lead of the
men in her life time and time again,
rarely striking out on her own terms.
"You desire not to be free, but to make
a window in the wall of your prison."
Beyond that, Nymeria would certainly have harsh
words for a woman who is actively supplanting
another woman's legitimate claim to the throne
by insisting that only a man can rule. Clearly,
Rhaenyra internalized a lot more about
Nymeria than Alicent did — then again,
after the end of the episode, it's clear that
Alicent's gesture won't even matter going forward.